[Music]
well
bella thorne
oh is that the fake hooker yeah was on
bill maher and um bill maher made her a
little upset man
let's see if he could figure out where
he was even born
it doesn't even matter because
everybody's switching their sexes
no i'm not kidding
but i mean i'm kidding about that but
people do switch sexes a lot more than
they used to
right here by the way i'll i'll i'll
break right here oh boy so she got mad
you see you can pinpoint the exact
moment her heart breaks bill maher
here's the thing with bill maher but
we've always said it you have to blame
you can't you have to blame him for
allowing it to get this way right
for for a lot of a lot of the stuff that
he pushed
is led to this
but i'm also a firm believer
is that i don't think either that bill
maher thought that yeah man gay people
should get married leave them alone
would turn to this either i think
there's a lot of people that are going
like
wait were we duped
we went too far with this right yeah
kind of like you rule okay
pick a lane with your genitals okay
you know we used to call that what what
was his uh the fake the the baseball
marsh brother
phil mart yeah it was phil maher by the
way it's just turning into bill maher
now because he's starting to say things
like no it's really just him well that's
how the bit started it was just knowing
like new rule okay let's round up all
these media and banking types
you know there's a lot of trends you
know i always
see that this this is this is bad i
should like warn you unless you're i
love whenever i love uncomfortable
things like this when somebody starts
going but you you know i was just you
know it's like a joke it gets more on
the joke it wasn't a joke but it's kind
of a joke it's more uncomfortable it
gets more uncomfortable
here we go
the paper about somebody who has
switched their sex which i'm all that's
what makes you yeah that's not what
blows your dress [ __ ] all the way yes
what
bad [ __ ] bro all the way i'm sorry
what bad [ __ ] all the way
bad [ __ ] fat [ __ ] bad [ __ ] oh
bad [ __ ] bad [ __ ] be who you are
this is like what this is what i imagine
it feels like
when he goes out with his hookers
nowadays yeah
yeah right like he's so out of touch and
they're like smoking weed and they're
like yo
oh my god you're right this is him at a
double tree that's just one of his dates
at the suite at the doubletree because
he doesn't bring him back home
he's at the suite at a double tree it's
a nice one because it has a hotel bar
bar at the dolphin that's right that's
what i was just saying bro
it's a nice one because it's a hotel bar
right
and he's sitting at the bar by the way
not even at the bar he's here sitting in
one of these because a lot of these
little bars now have this little setup
where there's two couches and a table in
the middle he's sitting like this at the
bar and all you hear over your shoulder
are people going like yeah uh martin i'm
staying until thursday okay sir we're
gonna need a credit card and he's
sitting there while they're playing some
[ __ ] ariana grande over the [ __ ]
speakers and he cannot relate to this
hooker in any way no there's no human
connection there and then eventually
somebody comes over and goes are we
doing separate checks or is your dad
just paying for everything oh
oh oh god you know that's happened you
know
i mean i think there's some uh money to
be made in some sort of exchange with
everyone switching where like you know
if you need a penis take a penis if you
have a penis give a penis you know like
if people are becoming like men is he
talking about like a leave a penis take
a penis thing like a like a penny thing
pennies right that yeah yeah okay the
women they're going to cut off their
penis does it bother you
that um
does it bother you that bill maher is
still dressing like he's in his uh 20s
or is it just me but he's so cool bro
he's smoking weed with bella thorne man
he's so cool
i'm 38 and i would be bored smoking weed
with bellathorne i'm 38 i'd be bored
smoking weed with any woman to be honest
with you
it is and then there are women
transitioning who are going to need a
penis
she's not happy
she's also stupid so
unhappy and stupid together aren't the
best combo
you know
yeah it's like pop rocks and soda uh i
feel like there was some
extra he's trying
so hard he's trying he is and i'm giving
him credit for he's trying to choke
and she is getting
very angry by the way i want to put
something out thank frozen for this he's
the one that sent this just keep that in
mind okay
whenever it's cringe stuff whenever it's
stuff that makes you angry
it's frozen
you're welcome no i didn't say thank you
you're welcome he says i don't don't
laugh at him
don't encourage him i love it don't
encourage him i like i like the frozen
starting to get like you know uppity
it's the best
but um when he does it to you um not to
me
exchange uh maybe bitcoin could be
involved
now he's trying he's throwing in modern
oh my god merch this is the hooker thing
you said he's throwing in modern
references he just said bitcoin
he's just trying he's trying his best he
just said bitcoin oh no this really does
feel like he's with a young hooker
oh
oh he said [ __ ] just said bitcoin
you think he's gonna say something's lit
you think he's gonna say he's gonna be
like yo man it's lit fam no cap yeah no
count
you couldn't press send dog
yeah in the chat said tick tock am i
right
i'm sorry the reason i'm laughing is i'm
thinking of this happening in our hotel
bar about the double tree
specifically by the way the hooker would
probably be dressed like this too and he
would be dressed like this this is
exactly what this would look like
this is terrifying the only difference
is at the end he didn't have to pay to
[ __ ] bella thorne
no
here it comes i'm i'm i know i know i'm
pausing a lot because i don't want to
hear this okay
but we're going to hear this
i just don't like joking about oh bella
i know that you like to but i just see
this is where you're funny
and also this would happen he would if
the hooker got uppity with him
he would he would be like at that point
realize look i'm paying for you so why
don't you just say yes to what i'm
saying just just agree with me yeah
let's let's i paid for the girlfriend
experience okay
that is not the [ __ ]
future ex-wife experience
you have to be sorry but i'm not sorry
either
and that is where your anxiety comes
from there is nothing wrong with joking
nothing wrong about that it's not
everybody is that sensitive not
everybody needs to be that sensitive
lumar
smokes pre-rolls
even the people who are doing that i
don't think would need to be offended by
that everybody is so easily offended
your kids you wake up offended you
should you should get off twitter get
off social media
and and maybe you wouldn't like have
this anxiety this like because yes
you're right bill we should all talk on
our on our weekly hbo show instead that
should be our outlet
because every hbo show because every
[ __ ] ham and egger
do not have an hbo show
every ham and egger out there that has
to punch a [ __ ] clock could oh cause
he could go on his [ __ ] his weekly
[ __ ] political show wait sorry bill
but unfortunately that's all some people
gots right that's their one outlet so
they don't feel like they're screaming
into the goddamn void
i don't know if you're really offended
or you're just worried that you're going
to look offended
that's
god that's actually a good point i did
like that point
is it people being offended or people
that are afraid they're going to get
criticized
no i'm
100
offended like when when i think about
you know someone's drama and someone
watch the videos that i have
shut
up
oh my god uh
with your cubic zirconia embezzled
invicta watch get the [ __ ] out of here
i've seen she bought that with her only
fans money mm-hmm
that looks like a it's like a
last-minute gift you buy at a cvs
that are so
like so [ __ ] bad
they're so bad she's gonna start crying
yeah she's gonna cry
much again a lot like bill maher's
hookers
this is this is the whole thing
i'm just doing this because i'm trying
to go back to community college but my
ex-boyfriend ain't [ __ ] so i got three
kids and i gotta do the okay
look man shut up
anyway we will continue
and
but you can people have to worry about
walking on the street just being
themselves like
you mean like being a [ __ ]
conservative anywhere in any major city
or how about this how about being an
asian guy around black people in new
york is that what you're talking about
does that i would have a lot of anxiety
if i was an asian person being around
black people in new york
hey man who are you going to take your
advice from okay
some right wing talking point or the
chick who
made her way because she was in the oc
i looked i had to look her up i don't
know what she was oh was that was she
the oc she was in the oc yeah i remember
i just all i remember is like she was
just all of a sudden around
and that's right disney [ __ ] she i
know her more is just being a train
wreck yes and then she was a then she
was a disney [ __ ] correct and because
she's a disney [ __ ] and she probably
wants to go back to being a disney [ __ ]
she can't unbe a disney [ __ ] because
then they won't invite her to be on her
shows because remember when they just
completely destroyed everybody's career
whoever said anything gina carano for
example now has to do daily wire movies
[ __ ] anxiety that's why i don't like
to like
that's [ __ ]
it's really hard i don't like the joke
yeah but does it [ __ ] matter what you
like whose show is this
is this her show
this is her show oh this is her show
okay well then you know what if it's her
show then kick him off i guess i was
wondering did she go on like bill
maher's podcast new rule okay if you're
gonna start it only fans show daddy that
hole
it's a good one i would i would it's
really good
joke about it because you know someone
hears it and on a public platform how
about this
we start our own show with fillmore you
have to play him okay with phil marshall
all right this would be great and we
call it political n-words
and that would be really good that would
get views black twitter would be on
board house n-words
i like that i like that platform is so
bad because you're like kind of low-key
spreading like this you're low-key
low-key low-key no cap no it's paralyzed
let's normalize being nice to transition
exactly
oh god you know where she was born
pembroke pines florida
yeah she's one of ours she's by the way
pembroke pines or as we call it slightly
nicer hollywood
um
i mean slightly by the way slightly
let's get ahead of ourselves pembroke
pines
we have a mall that's dying all right um
there is a latin american cafe there
though it's my favorite [ __ ] alex
stein dude look i'm not the one with the
dying them all bro i'm the one trying to
help you out i'll never forget that line
so good
it's like oh ha ha ha ha and it's like
it's not funny when your like face is
being beaten in the floor yes it is
who's beating your face into the floor
though well they're beating trans
people's faces into the floor
you know what you can connect
you can connect any bad thing with any
other bad thing of course there's a lot
of bad things
and he had a
song in it called springtime for hitler
if i really tried i could probably
connect hitler with something sad
[Laughter]
okay come on man
no come on man funny is funny [ __ ]
funny man bunny is stunned off his ass
he's funny okay god damn that was a
really good line if i try really hard i
was really connected to something bad
oh [ __ ]
that was good
by the way good delivery yeah someone's
thinking that was really good delivery
[ __ ] can i hear that again that was fine
by the way people in the chat are going
he's turning into phil maher he's just
we gotta hear that we gotta hear that
again the whole setup the whole setup
the whole setup i can connect
any bad thing with any other bad thing
of course there's a lot about this you
know what this is mel brooks did a movie
called
the producers and he had a
song in it called springtime for hitler
if i really tried i could probably
connect hitler with something sad
that's a good line man
i've never said that this dude wasn't
funny [ __ ] that was a really good line
yeah that was good oh man you know you
know what it is to make a good joke out
of holocaust survivor adolf hitler
that's pretty crazy
but we don't because that's not how we
live that's not how we can live because
everything can be connected
everything can be ready for this
conversation
or don't invite somebody who's going to
have forget you not having them don't
invite somebody who's going to have
strong opinions invite another [ __ ]
zendaya from [ __ ] euphoria whatever
[ __ ] [ __ ] invite some other actresses
demi lovato will talk to you about ghost
if you want why would you involve invite
a guy who literally gets paid to talk
about these things for a [ __ ] living
right like it's a dumb it's like
i'm not going to bring an nra member on
the show to talk to him about flowers
you know
i'm not going to do a weird interview
though that would be actually fun i'm
not going to invite alex stein on here
not to talk about gypsies it doesn't
make any sense or to be calm or to be
calm and soothing or wear pants
he wasn't wearing he wasn't wearing
pants everything can be connected to
something sad
and then you'll be sad all your life and
that's why you are sad and you don't
have to be sad
he's getting old man arms
not everything has to like i refer to
them as grandpa arms
we said not everything's the gym nor in
arms yeah yeah
well that's not true he's had specials
on hbo so let's not make comparisons
ouch yeah he's never been on epics
he had that show on vice for two seconds
oh yeah vice that's great how's vice
doing
uh not great
it could be said we choose ask the
shareholders of disney
make it sad or not
she's mad
yeah she seems pretty angry she is
[ __ ] pissed
you know you don't think there's
something to that theory i think when it
comes to your own drama like
you know like i i make dead dad jokes
make some people who know me very well
super uncomfortable sometimes wow so
you're a basic [ __ ] right so everything
is basically
yeah but but just
okay so it's your basic like i you know
it's this is a typical
you know it's really hard to offend me
but but yeah well i love i love a good
joke
most of my friends are guys
that's the olivia mon hot dog yeah
dude
what could be more sensitive than that
it's but like
for your own trauma like you you
you know it's
i don't know i i just but that's your
own trauma and you're okay with joking
this poor guy has to sit there and drink
smearing off pink i'm honestly feeling
bad for it i really am because she's
this is a great example though of how
these brain dead brainwashed retards
can't even like
articulate their points well another
great example of this is this is
an absolute perfect picture of
liberals from the 80s versus liberals
from today right like
they couldn't be any more different like
in every way
in what they believe
and what they think you should joke
about these this is a completely
different species you know
you just said
it's do i think it's really funny if
someone's joking about rape me a dead
dad joke i don't i don't think that
one's really funny that one's not so
funny and that's another trauma of mine
you know it's like it's another merch so
you're just a tr you're just a a useless
[ __ ] hole
filled with trauma he's just it's a
[ __ ] of trauma with her
[Laughter]
enough oh poor bella thorne it's disney
all over again
that's a good point
i have a feeling a lot of the guys look
like bill too
it depends on only one of us is a
comedian so i'm going to have to pull
rank on that but
god damn it
good for him
good for him
good
and by the way frozen [ __ ] you again for
this
dad joke oh no come on no no no you said
you were dead no i just like you know
it's it's it's not like i have a literal
dead dad joke it's more like you know
conversations are being had and you know
there's an opportunity to
you know make a dead dad joke like how
did we get here
how do we get to her making this because
her dad died i guess let me explain what
she's saying by the way because she's
saying tell me a dead dad joke she's
doing the typical immersion you've heard
this many of times nah i'm just going
like i'm riffing when i'm riffing with
my friends yeah we're just having fun we
like to have fun around here i'm the
king of the roast in my friend group the
roastmaster that's what they call me
they call me the roastmaster of my
friend's group
shut up
like you know and then you know here
again
i mean you know it's not mine it's the
way to open it
it's the way to own it yeah when you
decide to own your you know pain is
however you decide to own your pain yeah
but don't tell other people not to joke
about your pain
hey don't don't joke about my pain
don't come to my side
ah question and don't question my faith
you know what i'm going to another diner
i'm out of here
[Laughter]
honey get my man purse we're leaving get
my man purse we're leaving
uh this is not going well uh check
please sir you haven't ordered food you
thought that was gonna be a good line
though huh so this isn't even a
restaurant so this is a veterinarian's
office can you please leave you're
scaring the snakes
why snakes i don't know we specialize in
snakes it's a snake hospital
what a weirdly specific
and you're like the one guy that's on
sitting on the board at that hospital
going you know if we treat other animals
i think that we're probably gonna stay
in business longer yeah right now it's a
very niche market
oh [ __ ] i feel like if we start doing
cats and dogs where you can really start
getting some volume yeah listen we
already tried snake and mice and that
was a bloodbath
we probably should we probably shouldn't
have kept them all in the same areas
yeah we only had one room
people
the people with pet snakes though very
happy
yeah
kind of control me with this anyway what
are you doing here temple
i've recognized you on account of the
hat
i thought it was either it was either
gonna be you or or [ __ ] stan marsh
and i knew it wasn't him because we're
not in colorado
i mean i'm gonna own it it's like the
way
african-americans took black people
back the n-word oh boy now we're going
here you know what at this point hold on
can i explain something oh easy easy can
i explain something to you know you know
what he's doing right now he's doing the
like all right remember the classic
patrice when the girl was getting mad at
him and he just kept go now he's
escalating
he see he's really he's like all right
you know [ __ ] i don't need to be here i
came on your stupid little podcast with
my oh my god do his pants have writing
like those are designer pants oh man
bill dude just wear a suit everywhere
you're at that age now where you wear a
suit everywhere he's wearing russ
hanneman jeans oh no dude listen you
know what's acceptable
at that age by the way it's acceptable
to do jeans
with a blazer right that's still okay go
wear jeans with a blazer no one's gonna
be make fun of you for that nah he looks
so cool though jesus christ
he looks like the way elon musk dressed
when he when he was taking out amber
heard
oh god
it was touched a bullet with that one
huh yeah
little slur to be fair bill maher has a
better hairline i mean it's finally
going in a little bit but that's always
been his hair i'll give him that and
then they said but we're going to own it
you know
it's the same thing i don't think she
knows anything sir but bill let me help
you out here i don't think she knows
where she is
this doesn't look like somebody who is
high bill maher is high
she's acting like somebody who's high
but it's not just weed
this feels like
prescription town
oh no bella thorne's probably on a
ridiculous cocktail of antipsychotics
and antidepressants yeah yeah which it's
good to always you know be on both they
tell you to mix them with alcohol for
the best results of course you gotta get
the [ __ ] that extra kick yeah and you
think she's gonna stop drinking sort of
like pro wrestlers used to do with somas
and carbs yep
and
anyway
drop a soma bomb in your beer bro
look
i it's good that we can agree to
disagree we don't have to agree on
everything that's what an honest
conversation is you know anyway
um i got to be up tomorrow early so if
we're going to do this let's go up to
the room
yeah let's get this over with plus i
only paid you for two hours and we think
we've talked enough i think i've i know
your level of intelligence here let's
get this over with
uh-huh but i bet you
like in ten years
when
when i'm dead
and you're here hosting the show
i don't think sh she's going to be
hosting politically incorrect with bella
thorne
well that means somebody you know don't
rule it out we're getting that stupid
idiocracy future i was asking this the
other day better movie idiocracy or
office space
i still like office space it's
idiocracy whatever
by the way the poll that i put up on
twitter
office space one
i know where i'm going with that yeah
because it's a better movie 59
it's a better movie
idiocracy though
i don't know paintballs of fruit and
[ __ ]
idiocracy is great
you know well you know office space is
better no you're not a big extract fan
that third mike judd movie that nobody
watched with jason bateman oof you're
not a big extract guy you just made me
sad yeah i
know we're all in the process of
evolution me too
okay so that's pretty much
uh
then she runs in it well
again
bill please stop going on these
children's show
it's kind of weird now yeah it is really
i'd rather you be on a children's show
yeah i mean seriously do the rounds and
like you know do some of the older
political talk shows i get that but